[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti in un nuovo video
nuova avventura assieme nuova challenge
del castello stiamo ancora nel castello
siamo resi conto di una cosa molto
importante
beh no mentre io stavo parlando non ha
però fruttato cioccolatino e allora
perché ai miei dato solo la buccia è
perché erano confezionati cosa ci vuole
dire il resto non ho mangiato dai subito
in prigione dai rivoluzione era così
buono guidare in prigione ci siamo
dimenticati di una cosa importantissima
giornata da abbiamo mangiato siamo
dimenticati una cosa importante vi
ricordate la scorsa lettera che abbiamo
ricevuto dal re nella lettera diceva
vediamo se trovate il cavaliere non
trovano un cavaliere non avete visto
l'episodio precedente
andate a vederlo ora è meglio che
iniziamo a cercare subito il cavaliere
altrimenti non so cosa potrebbe
succedere ma non ci è arrivata nessuna
altra lettera ho quindi sicuramente
dobbiamo trovare il cavaliere nello
scorso episodio abbiamo esplorato tutto
il castello dallo sterno ma non abbiamo
esplorato tutto l'interno del castello
dobbiamo cercare il cavaliere e vediamo
se riusciamo a trovare
stiamo dentro al castello
1520 duguay
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi ha chiamato
abbiamo trovato il cavaliere dobbiamo
fare silenzio per non disturbare gli
altri abitanti del castello
enorme
per il mondo e non prenda vista ma
aspetta c'entra qualcosa qui
qui un po paura a prenderlo però guarda
che cos'è
un'altra lettera un'altra lettera del re
questa la prima o dopo
ora continua ad esplorare il castello ma
fate scherzi
guardate che vista
quasi visto che io comunque ancora un po
paura di quel cavaliere non devono
controllare che vuol dire punti si è
spostato per la metà non mi lasciare
solo con questo ci sono tantissimi libri
antichi
forse nascosto dentro questi libri c'è
qualche segreto che dovremo scoprire
sono tanti in tantissimi infatti si qui
facciamo leggermi tutti si avrà
bellissima vista anche d'acqua e voi
vivreste qui o vi farebbe paura e ci
vivrei qui ma solo tu la condizione se
ci fossero tantissime cose da mangiare
io fossi seduto sul tavolo potessi
mangiare tutto quello che vuoi beh mi
dispiace informarti che non sei tu il re
anzi dobbiamo ancora conoscere
conoscerlo perché questi amarezza si
sento delle voci
qualcuno che ridà forse questi sono gli
abitanti del castello di cui parlava
cacciarli
ok non c'è niente qua il colpo anche se
sembra che si sia spostato era sempre lì
ma non fatti adesso nessuno si è fatto
più avanti non so perché ma un brutto
presentimento su questo cavaliere voi
forse esista un momento
[Musica]
non lo so per capire
siamo riusciti a scappare dal castello
fortuna anche perché c'era qualcosa di
pistoia era perso la sembra voci strane
ora dobbiamo solo aprire questa lettera
forse meglio spostarsi la mano nemici
dalle coste mi sembra un'ottima idea
[Musica]
stiamo uscendo dalle carte andiamo nei
giardini del castello così forse non
verremo a disturbarci ottime che andiamo
a quest'ora il castello è bellissimo
guarda se io fossi in questa panchina
antica forse qua non ci disturberà
nessuno perché stiamo bene scotti si
rimedia dobbiamo né all'estero
cosa ci sarà una volta complimenti siete
sopravvissuti finora ma non è finita qui
anzi abbiamo appena cominciato provate a
nascondervi tra le mura del mio castello
ma attenti a non perdervi o peggio
attenti a non essere catturati e chiusi
nelle segrete per sempre le segrete chi
vincerà questa challenger riceverà in
dono un vestito nobile degno del
castello buona fortuna
il re come verrà chiuso nelle segrete
per sempre no e che cosa mangiano le
segrete stai sempre senza da mangiare e
figlio che mi danno pane duro e acqua
come faccio a lei più paura invece di
essere rinchiuso per sempre nella
prigione del castello si rinchiuso per
sempre perche ero così non posso più
mangiare quello che voglio vabbè
comunque che cosa dobbiamo fare
esattamente bce provate a nascondervi
tra le mure del mio cartello attenti a
non perderli
quindi dobbiamo semplicemente giocare a
nascondino e chi vince vincerà un
vestito nobile degno del castello
no io lo vorrei sinceramente 1 destino
un vestito nobile del tempo lo vorrei
proprio io non mi fiderei tanto potrebbe
essere maledetto anche il vestito magari
a qualche talismano qualche bottone
non sto in ogni caso dobbiamo iniziare
subito alla challenge
altrimenti si arrabbierà e potrebbe
chiudersi entrambi nelle segrete voi
lasciate un mi piace per portarci
fortuna chi si nasconde per primo
[Musica]
[Applauso]